this next story is just hilarious but
it's also infuriating in a way and I'll
tell you why Donald Trump's former
defense secretary Jim mattis who was
always one of the people with a head on
his shoulders
other than being a total tool of
militarism Jim mattis was more or less
sensible more or less connected to
reality when it came to Trump being a
clueless person
madis reportedly said we're now learning
back when Trump wanted to do that
ridiculous fourth-of-july military
parade with the tanks that would destroy
the roads and the entire thing Jim
mattis reportedly said I'd rather
swallow acid that's a quote I'd rather
swallow acid than watch Trump's military
parade now I like this because it
confirms that mattis not only had a
sense of how ridiculous Trump's actions
were he also had sort of a clever sense
of humor the book we're talking about is
called holding the line inside Trump's
Pentagon with secretary mattis which was
written by retired navy commander guys
Snodgrass Snodgrass was mattis's
communications director and head
speechwriter and the book has a ton of
interesting stuff in it not the least of
which is mad as his preference for
swallowing acid over watching Donald
Trump's military parade the book also
says that Trump wanted to squat screw
Amazon CEO and turbo billionaire Jeff
Bezos by keeping Amazon out of the
bidding process for a Pentagon contract
for some kind of big networked computing
networking IT installation so the trend
of most of what's in the book is in line
with everything we've seen Donald Trump
do which is there's always a personal
angle to it Trump is president and he's
supposed to be doing what's best for the
United States but Pentagon networking
contract
I want to screw Jeff Bezos military aid
to Ukraine
I want Ukraine to smear Biden for the
benefit of my 2020 reelection campaign
and the real embarrassment is that for
anything we can say about maddest now he
understands Trump is bonkers he wanted
to swallow acid instead of watch the
parade whatever where was mad as earlier
right well why didn't mattis stand up to
trump
sooner and we know the answer and
unfortunately you know Trump did untold
damage through decisions that maddest
tried to stand up to Trump about he
would have been fired or forced to
resign obviously but he could have done
it maddis has buyer's remorse from
working for Donald Trump but where was
that assessment at the start Trump it's
a we didn't have to wait and see who
Donald Trump was going to be as
president Trump as president is exactly
who we knew him to be the day he hired
Jim mattis and natus went along with it
for a long time and it's important to
accept the accurate statements of these
former Trump officials to the extent
that they're accurate now in hindsight
but we can't allow them to rehabilitate
their images so easily we discussed this
yesterday on the bonus show actually we
talked about it with regard to Sean
Spicer former just embarrassingly bad
dishonest press secretary who now is
rehabbing his image on I didn't even
know this Pat told me on Dancing with
the Stars
Sarah Huckabee Sanders who is I don't
really know what she's doing but she
could potentially at some point be
governor of Arkansas who knows a long
list of people who as soon as they leave
the administration and they sort of seem
to be connected with reality we often
immediately improve our opinion of them
it's great that they're recognizing it
now but the truth is they probably
recognize that then they said nothing
they saw only their personal career
potential that was associated with
participating in this completely
abortive presidency and we should not
allow them to rehabilitate their image
in the way that they are so so obviously
trying to do at this point in time
there's other remind me who else there
is I mean I obviously I know Spicer and
Huckabee are two of the big players Rex
Tillerson although he doesn't really
need to rehab his image he's you know
ready to retire at least financially if
not ideologically but there are others
and we've got to be really careful about
allowing them to now just be seen as
normal people because there's nothing
normal about going along with it for the
weeks months or years that they did
before they said I can't do this anymore
or Trump kicked him out